podrían por favor todos ustedes
ayudándome levantando su mano si alguna
vez escucharon la tan famosa frase no
dejes para mañana lo que puedes hacer
hoy
sí claro y yo también y me lo han dicho
principalmente pues mis papás mis
maestros mis abuelos y es válido a veces
una persona que procrastinar un poco las
cosas pero cuando mis abuelos me lo
decían había algo de transfondo había
había algo que yo no estaba entendiendo
y no entendía por ninguna manera que era
que eso que ellos veían yo no lo veía el
no entender esto me llevó a la próxima
estadística una persona según el inegi
promedio en méxico vivirá 80 años 960
meses o dicho de otras palabras tendrán
960 oportunidades de ya sea crear un
hábito o dejar aquel viejo vicio después
de saber esta estadística mi pregunta
fue por qué porque si sabemos que estas
oportunidades día con día se nos van a
acabar
por qué seguimos postergando las cosas
para mañana porque esperamos hasta la
cuaresma pareja al llegar porque
esperamos hasta navidad para
reconciliarnos con esa persona especial
porque año nuevo para ir al gimnasio o
el 14 de febrero para decir un te quiero
porque si sabemos que todas estas
oportunidades se nos van a acabar
hoy yo tengo 23 años doscientos setenta
y seis meses de vida y quiero compartir
con ustedes que en enero del año pasado
hoy está sintiendo un poco mal empezar
con el doctor cuando hace unos estudios
rece con el doctor estudios llegó al
consultorio me siento y me dice tienes
cáncer
entonces después de esa noticia la
expectativa de 960 meses fue por unos
momentos esto yo realmente en ese
momento tuve miedo tuve unos días donde
en las quimioterapias y perdí un poco la
esperanza de que si tendría un mañana
que las cosas iban a salir bien que
tenía esa oportunidad de decir mañana
empieza a ser feliz mañana hago lo que
me gusta mañana le digo te quiero esa
muchacha entonces en estos días yo me
puse a pensar cómo había estado viviendo
mi vida que había hecho que no había
hecho entre esto recordé la tan famosa
frase de malcolm gladwell donde dice
hacen falta 10.000 horas pues una
persona extraordinaria en cualquier cosa
que te dediques
es mi conclusión con esto fue ok 10.000
horas 10.000 horas son 15 años
aproximadamente 15 años trabajando 2
horas diarias dos horas diarias en tu
deporte dos horas diarias dibujando en
facebook ser bueno que hay personas
expertas en estrenos no siempre es
tiempo perdido entonces con estas
conclusiones me di cuenta que las
personas que habían logrado esto al
morir al dejar este planeta lo dejaron
con mucho más amor muchos más sueños y
sobre todo muchas más y nuevas metas
esperando a ser cumplidas
incluso incluso pudiendo inspirar a una
persona que está al otro lado del mundo
que nunca los conoció a lograr seguir su
legado
en resumen tuvieron una vida
significativa yo me di cuenta que yo no
estaba viviendo 100% con esta idea
no no estaba viviendo con esta idea como
yo quería vivirla entonces me dediqué a
encontrar tres ideas que creo firmemente
pueden ayudarnos a vivir una vida
significativa y feliz pero sobre todo
preparada para las adversidades que la
vida nos pueda presentar primera idea
ser como niños seamos como niños si yo
te pregunto en qué momento de tu vida
recuerdas haber sonreído y disfrutado
más es probable que me digas que cuando
eras un pequeñito con 'las un niño tras
una pelota jugando escondidas o las tres
pero hay algo que frecuentemente pasa y
hay un libro el principito que nos ayuda
a ilustrarlo muy bien todos los adultos
en un principio fueron niños pero muy
pocos de ellos lo recuerdan
y desde pequeños nos han enseñado
principalmente tres cosas nuestros papás
sonríe agradece y se fiel a ti mismo
primer punto sonríe sonríe tal vez se
escuche tan fácil pero yo sé que en
muchos momentos en la vida va a ser muy
complicado encontrar una encontrar solo
una razón para sonreír en estos momentos
quiero que por favor pienses y que
recuerdes el pajarito no canta porque
está feliz él es feliz porque decide
cantar él decide empezar a cantar y es
feliz esto traducido a nosotros es
sonríe sonríe cuando tú sonríes le
mandas a tu cerebro una señal que va
libera endorfinas que van a ayudar a que
se reduzca el estrés y la ansiedad
primer paso agradece segundo punto
agradece
si me recuerdan mamá y papá diciéndome
desde chiquitos agradecer a tus maestros
agradece las tuti os agradece esta hora
desde el otro y normas sociales
protocolo sí lo pensé así en su momento
pero hoy hoy me cuenta que que acá que
dices gracias gracias por mis amigos
gracias por mi familia gracias por un
día más de vida te das cuenta de las
cosas que la vida te está dando de los
regalos que la vida te está ofreciendo
entonces agradece y tercer punto en
cuanto a ser fiel a ti mismo éste sólo
dos preguntas primero qué esperas de tu
vida y segundo que estás haciendo
ahorita en este momento si esas
respuestas tienen congruencia
felicidades van por muy buen camino
segunda idea llena tus días de amor
llena tus días de amor sé que muy
probablemente un martes 5 y media de la
mañana suena la alarma podemos abrir un
ojo con esfuerzos elevarnos el otro y lo
primero que pasó por nuestra cabeza es
nuestro día
tener
tenemos un trabajo tenemos escuela
tenemos exámenes junta con los clientes
la familia la novia etcétera etcétera
etcétera y bueno al final del día tal es
regresamos a nuestra casa y logramos
todo muy bien felicidades pero estamos
por acostarnos y ya estamos pensando
hijo la mañana se repite y luego el
jueves y el viernes bueno viene fin de
semana pero el lunes es lo mismo y
realmente no nos damos cuenta de lo que
está pasando en nuestra vida en ese
momento tal vez llega hasta el tráfico
súper cansado y logras te algo en tu día
pero llega y cansada mente llegas y
cenas tu comida favorita también son los
taquitos no sé la suya o tal vez te
encontraste con tus amigos se pudieron
poner al día
platicaron y estoy por allá en la flecha
azul
sobre todo tal vez lo más importante es
que viste a tu familia cómo viviste con
ellos
estuviste un rato y aquí aquí yo tomé la
foto aquí estoy
por más que hayamos logrado en un día
por más que hayamos dicho hoy logré todo
lo que tenía si no nos prestamos un poco
de atención y un poco de detalle a esos
regalos que la vida nos está queriendo
dar al final de nuestra vida lo único
que tendremos que será días vacíos días
vacíos en donde no recordaremos qué fue
lo que pasó qué oportunidad dejamos
pasar o que te quiero ni siquiera
escuchamos para que esto no suceda yo
propongo que después de cada una de
nuestras actividades después de cada
examen después de cada charla de hoy
después de cada día te preguntes solo
una cosa de menos de 30 segundos que de
lo que acabo de hacer me gustó
para de esta manera llenar nuestros días
de amor y de alegrías
tercera idea siempre siempre voltea
hacia arriba
es muy probable después de este
grandioso sismo evento vamos a llegar
nuestras casas con ganas de comernos el
mundo con ganas de cambiar y empezar a
hacer hoy la persona que queremos ser y
con esto debe decirles vendrán grandes
oportunidades vendrán grandes logros
para cada uno de ustedes pero y hay que
decirlo también vendrán muchos y grandes
retos para todos la pregunta es cómo le
hacemos para superar esos retos si
alguno en alguna ocasión ha ido de
escalar entenderá la fuerza que se
necesita para poder llegar hasta la cima
o para el simple hecho de no caerse sin
importar la fuerza que tenga alguien es
muy probable que en algún momento en esa
subida tú creas que tus piernas tus
brazos tu espalda ya están tan cansados
que ya no te dan y no hay ningún lugar
donde vais a poder descansar porque
bueno estás a diez metros de altura y
donde descansas entonces si en un
momento dado tú sigues escalando sigues
esforzándote quieres llegar hasta arriba
y resbalar y caes
yo esperaría que la cuerda que tenemos
amarrada el arnés no nos vaya a soltar
si no nos suelta podemos descansar un
poco y seguir en nuestra meta de la
misma manera yo les quiero compartir los
que invitar a todos ustedes a que tengan
esta cuerda en su vida que no la que no
la suelten nunca yo no sé ninguna de las
creencias de cada uno de ustedes lo que
yo sí sé es que después de creer haber
dado todo después de creer que ya no
tenemos ninguna fuerza más para dar nada
extra de energía y ni gasolina y la
única manera de poder seguir adelante es
tener fe y tener esperanza de que hay
alguien allá arriba que te quiere y que
nunca te va a soltar y de algo estoy
seguro es que esa es una muy buen primer
paso para tener una vida significativa y
feliz entonces recapitulando recuerda
estos tres pasos pequeños en tu día a
día ser como niños 30 segundos y voltear
siempre hacia arriba
hoy no algún día porque porque después
cuando llegamos el café ya está frío yo
no sé como quieran vivir el resto de su
vida pero les tengo una pregunta piensen
en cuántas bolitas les quedan
pongamos a pensar cómo quieren vivir
cada uno de estos circulitos que les
quedan yo hoy gracias a dios mis amigos
familia los doctores todo va bien y
estoy en remisión y trato de disfrutar
mi vida espero ustedes también lo hagan
y si misticidad spears con las palabras
para cada uno de ustedes serían las de
este que es mi poema favorito no me
importa lo que haces para ganarte la
vida quiero saber lo que ansias y si te
atreves a soñar con lograr lo que tu
corazón desea no me interesa la edad que
tengas quiero saber si estás dispuesto a
quedar como un tonto por amor por tus
sueños por la aventura de estar vivo
[Aplausos]